Monday morning in the business district of
Bamenda.
It's a sad sight: whole neighborhoods of the
biggest city in the region have come to a
standstill -- most businesses remain closed.
Greengrocer Robert isn't opening his shop
today - even though he badly needs to.
"It is a very difficult situation but if you
can imagine on a day like this some of us
we live on a daily bread meaning that today
there is no bread.
Today there is no bread but we adapt because
it's a cause that we are fighting for."
Robert says he hasn't seen any development
in the region -- even though he regularly
pays his taxes.
He and others are protesting by not opening
their businesses and they're also calling
for the release of a number of demonstrators.
In the mostly English-speaking west of Cameroon,
many people feel marginalized.
They feel they've been forgotten by President
Paul Biya and the French-speaking majority
of the country.
In late 2016, lawyers took to the streets
to protest.
Teachers soon followed suit - then finally
people from all walks of life.
The authorities responded with a heavy hand.
At least six people died and dozens were arrested.
Internet access in the region was blocked
for three months.
"We tried to talk to the governor about the
situation, but he didn’t grant us an interview.
A government spokesperson told us on the phone
that actions are more important than words
and they are working on a solution.
But here most people complain that they don’t
see any serious dialogue.
Instead, some people become more radical."
Businesses owned by people who did not take
part in the protest are often the target of
arson attacks.
We talks to a young man who wants to remain
anonymous.
He himself was almost arrested.
He wants the region to become independent.
He thinks the use of violence is legitimate,
because he doesn't think the government would
allow a referendum.
"It's a necessary evil.
I wouldn't say setting people's properties
on fire is a good thing.
But it's a necessary evil as of now.
If I have to tell you everything that runs
through my head, I might look like a terrorist to you.
But I'm not a terrorist!
But when you look at the frustration, when
the frustration mounts to a certain extent
you cannot contain, you become radical.
That's what happens.
We are just hoping that sometime soon somebody
will come and say: Here are the guns you need,
take them and fight for your freedom!
And we will just so do!"
The mood in the city is tense.
Divisions between radicals and moderates have
widened.
The Church has tried to mediate -- and is
calling on all parties to engage
in dialogue.
Robert the greengrocer is also hoping that
there will be a peaceful resolution, and that
the government finally responds.
Schools have been closed for over a year now
and his kids have been affected.
Robert says the current situation cannot continue.